sans le savoir tu as plus d'une tonne
sur tes épaules car l'air a un poids et
c'est pas léger à l'intérieur de la
Gymnasia l'équivalent d'un éléphant
alors imagine ce que ça pèse de l'espace
jusqu'au sol comment tu fais pour pas
mourir écraser par la pression des
centaines de kilomètres cubes
d'atmosphère au-dessus de toit on voit
bien que tu galères avec les 60 kg du
squat hein heureusement le sang l'eau et
l'air à l'intérieur de ton corps ont
aussi une pression en circulant il
pousse vers l'extérieur avec une force
équivalente à celle de l'atmosphère
autour de toi de force qui s'opposent un
équilibre parfait créé par des millions
d'années d'évolution c'est pour ça que
dans l'espace sans atmosphère notre
corps se dilate il n'y a plus rien pour
le retenir à l'inverse au fond de
l'océan nos organes sont écrasés par la
pression de l'eau heureusement sur Terre
on craint rien même si